la défaite présidentielle et les fracas
du mois de janvier ne semble pas avoir
abattu donald trump
l'hypothèse d'un retour en force fait
frémir les soutiens du 45e président des
états unis déjà enthousiaste à l'idée de
voir leur leader revenir à la maison
blanche en 2024
c'est une fête pour les trump heist du
monde entier c'est un mouvement qui ne
peut être ni arrêté ni ralenti peu
importe qui est au pouvoir en ce moment
nous le faisons et nous voulons soutenir
notre président nous l'aimons il a fait
un excellent travail en lui a volé
l'élection
je suis contente qu'il soit de retour
il est le président du peuple c'est le
président du peuple il ya beaucoup de
gens au chum tonnes qui voudrait juste
effacer les quatre dernières années
eh bien laissez moi vous dire quelque
chose donald trump ne va pas disparaître
s'il souhaite revenir dans le jeu
politique avec succès trump devra
rassembler le camp républicain
tout le monde n'étant pas convaincu que
son investiture comme candidat soit la
meilleure option
je ne pense pas qu'il devrait jouer un
rôle dans l'avenir de notre parti ou du
pays
la voix officielle du camp démocrate
désormais au pouvoir assure pour sa part
ne pas prêter une grande attention aux
tribuns de 74 ans nous ne nous
concentrons certainement pas sur ce que
dit ruff déclaré ainsi la semaine
dernière james zaki porte-parole de
l'administration de biden
quoi qu'il en soit le mouvement trump
heist que certains pensaient enterré
avec la fin du mandat du milliardaire
pourrait encore être au centre de
nombreux débats dans les années à venir